all right so I want you to uh I want you
guys to experience firstand the points
that we just went over I want you to
experience them not just watch them in
the video but I want the people in
patreon to understand more clearly what
my criticism is okay so um at some point
as we watching the videos okay I'm going
to come around and I'm going to cut down
good step back please okay and he's
going to be in this uh stance
okay and if you I'm holding here his
wrist and his head it's common in the
videos that we saw and what I want you
to do is straighten your knees and now
bend your knees as much as you want and
there's nothing I can do to stop him
from doing this from holding his wrist
and being on the top of his head okay so
he comes back and I want you to I don't
know what you want to do if you want to
grab his neck and grab here really hard
and he could do whatever he wants I
cannot stop that
okay that's the first thing I want you
to do get in those positions and try to
try to stop him from bending his knees
and
okay however you want to try but you
have to hold here and you have to hold
here and you have to leave your feet
here okay and then I want them to go
ahead and bend their knees and you could
use this hand on the ground cuz I can't
stop that either
okay and I want you to try and push him
over whatever means you want okay got it
and you're you're going to see that you
can't push him over okay and then I want
you to try to make him turn and he's
going to use that same base to not let
me turn not let me turn
him okay got it so again see if you can
controls knee bed two try to push him
any way you want into the forward roll
three try to turn him into some sort of
Ura variant
okay and then uh um four I want you to
come underneath my control points and
push me
over you're going to come towards me
your switch
rolles
okay we're here like this and I you stop
me from going into got
it this is four don't let me go into you
can push my head away same
thing and then
five okay you're here do you see this
leg right here and drive your shoulder
in ankle pick push you with your
leg do it one more time come around if
you can't
see you're here so push down control all
right here we
go all right let's
go okay so he's just in that three-point
stance okay uh you can bend your knees
so I would bend my knees cuz all right
I'm I'm going to base out um there's no
reason at all as we demonstrate right in
the first one why you would stick your
ass up in the air like that do do you
get it so you would bend your knees and
I can't stop you from doing that okay
this will stabilize your base and then
if we take the second and third one I
can't push and I can't pull well this
means there's
no as it's usually practiced and then
there's no Ura either as it's usually
practiced you cannot get it to go okay
why does does it usually work because he
gets a que and he does a forward
roll or he's down so your Q or your Q he
does his forward
roll or for the Ura he gets a q over
here do you see and he comes with
me okay but it's nothing I did to him he
just he's obeying the cues of the
choreography okay
um the next one I brought
up is there's no room for the
Emi so you have two variants that are
the one the more common one let me do it
please he obeys the cues and he starts
to roll and then I so I do a
yashi or as chibba used to do he would
do
yashi
okay the
Tashi uh does not require room like the
yashi can you guys see that okay so
but get your good base and don't let me
push
you okay but and what could he do the
entire time that I'm trying to TW that
arm he'll ankle pick don't do
it okay he'll ankle kick me and I'm
done okay so I know I can't push
him and if I could by the time I would
he'd pick my ankle I'm out okay so we're
going to look at the aashi go ahead let
me
please okay and most people get in a
dilemma and I either am here or I am
have head control so try to stand up try
to lift your head you can't cuz my
weight is on my hand but now I have no
room for that step if he doesn't want to
move so most people will create
room and now don't hurt me but just try
to get your head up and I don't have
leverage to keep that head down okay so
your next experiment
is get your weight over your hand have
your UK try to push up they should not
be able to lift the head then Hold Your
Position UK and don't let me step and
I'm not going to be able to step okay
again exercise one hold the head
exercise two holding the head try to
step there's no room for it you UK is
not going to create room for you
exercise
three come back make sure there is room
for the Thro
so here you can kind of use your leg to
throw
[Music]
him but because you're back here you
have room now have your ukas stand up
against your will okay all right here we
go try
it okay the uh next one
is that if he has his arm
out anytime I pull this arm back in any
way in downward action I'm actually
pinning that foot okay and so uh when I
pull down on this
arm that foot's not going to come back
okay so uh I'm working
this the foot can't come
back and the more I pull down and the
stronger I
am the more that foot cannot come
back
this in what I'm doing okay and you use
this idea all the time right so let's
just take regular cou net I'm going to
lead him
forward right and at a certain point
that foot becomes pinned otherwise I
can't get him to Pivot around or
something like that you put weight on
the foot it's no different probably the
easiest example find St okay and when I
check here I'm going to put weight on
that foot so he try to kick
me with that very intention in mind okay
so he grabs and he keeps his grip please
keep your grip no matter what I
do and he can't take that step come
back and take that step you have to do
whatever it takes to step back for this
foot step back
with okay whatever it takes you step
back with that foot there you go and if
you pay attention he's moving ahead of
me you see so he put himself there I
didn't put him there
okay it doesn't matter if you're doing
sto he has to do the same thing I will
put weight on it otherwise so he has to
do
it and that's violating the rule that I
UK If UK could move that
foot he could have moved it anywhere he
could have done anything with it do you
understand okay so let's try those two
efforts go okay as I said before if if
it's choreographed then UK or an
adversary could do whatever they want
with that leg because it's them moving
there well they wait please they can
attack as well with that leg so scoot
off the wall and we'll combine some of
the
information as he goes
go and we'll keep
going he's just putting it all
together and one
more all right so qu Pop Quiz well why
is that not
happening in the kihon waza when it's
done this
way it's not part of the choreography
that's the only reason why that doesn't
happen over and over and over again
okay okay the other point I made was the
range of the throwing engine and by
which I mean like imagine you have like
some ballistic projectile it has a
certain range in which it will function
as designed and then outside of that
range it starts to lose momentum and
gravity starts to take over okay it just
doesn't have enough
range range here is does it have enough
range to actively and directly move the
line of gravity outside the base of
support that's the question okay so if
he's in that three-point stance again
and we know that the line of gravity is
a theoretical line from his Center
gravity
drawn perpendicular to the Earth that's
the line of gravity his Bas of support
are his his feet his contact points with
the Earth and then all that shaded in
area between them right now his line of
gravity falls directly within his base
of support and hence he is balance
okay um don't resist me for me to
actively directly take take him off
balance I have to move that line of
gravity outside that basis support that
means my hands must make it outside that
foot do do you guys got that so if I
push
it and for some reason I had enough
ballistic energy to now indirectly send
that line of gravity out cool okay but
that is a very low percentage throw in
my opinion I better I should probably
kick them or strike them what I mean
directly is that my
hands will be able to remain contact
with what I'm
moving but keep and thereby directly
move his line of gravity out okay so for
example let's say I I ballistically move
your line of gravity and then you move
it back back in afterwards do you see
but as I'm doing this now move it back
nope back in there you go my hands are
in the way you get that which means I'm
actively moving that line of gravity
outside the Bas of support are you with
me okay and we always do that otherwise
the throw is not guaranteed the throw is
chore choreography
okay
so when I'm out here
and you
watch where do I actively go and you can
see that this hand I don't know it feels
like it's near his foot is it near his
foot on this plane do you see that but
not past his foot and therefore once I
run out of engine he'll come back into
me unless I hold him there but he's
definitely not
rolling
okay towards that end another
a place where this engine doesn't have
the force necessary for an active direct
throw this arm
angle the way they're taking the arm it
never really affects the hips so you're
going to look I'm going to maybe do it
the cha Sensei version you
see and let's take this is where I
feel the tension in there at this point
in space okay and now here as I go don't
let me break your shoulder but it's
about here that that that hip on this
side starts to be affected you see
that so let's go back to your stance
there I
am plotted in
space and let's see how far I have to
move it past that before it starts to
affect the hips okay all the way out
here Plott it in space come
back and I'm right at the edge I need to
go way past there do you guys see
that what usually happens is he just
goes with the cubes and it look like
that arm was doing something but it's
not
okay
so we have to do a couple things for the
for the mul
version is I have to find room for my
Emi and I need to add more angles into
this shoulder so that it impacts more
his line of gravity so instead of going
this way I'm going to go this way you
see that and then his head I'm going to
help bring it closer which allows this
to affect that hip sooner
okay he's
down you're
here I'm going to enter on on the
curve so there's room and I
pull don't go that way go this
way and I'll affect that hit which hit
back down this
hit so here I come in and I start to
turn this this way as I turn it I make
space for
me and I affect that hip all right let's
try that one for
this is dealing with the most
mechanically